- So we have more details
about what is happening to Joel Greenberg.
In the Northern District of Florida.
As was expected,
he has signed a cooperation
deal with federal prosecutors.
Number one, he is pleading guilty to six
of the 33 counts that he was charged with.
He's admitting that he's paid over $70,000
for over 150 sex acts, that he
has defrauded the government,
that he has stolen money from
taxpayers in Northern Florida.
And perhaps most
importantly, he has agreed
to cooperate with federal prosecutors.
And of course the papers themselves
don't name Matt Gates by name,
but one has to wonder why
would federal prosecutors
sign a cooperation agreement
if he wasn't agreeing to cooperate
against someone higher up
in the food chain?
And really all roads
point to Matt Gates here.
So in all likelihood,
we will probably see Matt Gates in court.